I got the sense that Kirsten was having
a bit of fun that prime minister's
questions when he very kindly offered to
you know be the help that Richard C Nick
needed well I don't know if it's about
sort of having fun actually I think it's
about doing the right thing in the
National interest which is why Kia has
said that you know labor would lend its
support to a deal so that we can get
something over the line that's in the
National interest I think he's really
right to offer that support and Labor's
right to offer that
um support seems at the moment the Rishi
soon act seems to be scared of his own
benches and that stopping progress from
being made it's not just being scared
everything about benches though is it
it's also taking into consideration the
views of the dep people like to Jeffrey
Johnson who are genuinely concerned
about what it means for the future of
the Union yeah you know I think we've
been having these conversations now for
the past five or six years in Parliament
you know we promised a oven ready brexit
deal by Boris Johnson it's clear that
that wasn't the case it was clear at the
time that that wasn't the case and now
we're continuing to have these these the
these arguments um I think a deal is
there to be done with the European Union
but it's about getting that over the
line now so you're willing to lend your
votes and to to get that done if it does
mean some of those issues in Northern
Ireland and as you see it would be so
yeah absolutely so what would you say
then to you know we're going to be
interviewing uh the Deep who's Jim
Shannon a bit later what would you use
to say to him someone who has genuine
concerns about you know the role of for
example the European courts or Northern
Ireland or having different rules apply
to different parts of the same country I
mean I think the issue with the European
court is that you know actually I think
people at the moment in Northern Ireland
what they're more concerned about is
certainty about what's going to happen
uh getting the assembly uh up and
running uh again and things like cost of
living I think people are more concerned
about that actually at the moment than
they are about whether it's the ecj or
some other mechanism that that regulates
things and you know I just think we need
to get something done now we need that
certainty in place we need the assembly
back up and running and that's why we
would lend our support to a deal I'm
Keen to talk as well about shamima begum
and the girl of course who was 15 years
old when she left the UK to join Islamic
State
today she had her appeal she lost her
appeal to return to the UK to be allowed
to be a British citizen citizen again it
was that the right decision I'll start
by saying it was a really really
troubling uh case
um
she went there at 15 it sounds like she
was radicalized here the judge made some
comments in his judgment today about you
know the fact that there may have been
child sexual sexual exploitation it is
really deeply worrying but there are
also National Security concerns and that
has to be the absolute priority the
hearing was a private hearing because of
those National Security concerns so we
don't know everything that all of the
evidence that was presented at that
hearing
um
I've got the confidence though in the
British justice system about making the
right decisions on these things and
happening we have to respect the
decision that the court made today in
light of those very serious National
Security concerns I guess what some
would say is you know the issues that
you had the concerns about her being a
child when it happened was she groomed
was their sexual exploitation others
would also say even if they were left
sympathetic to her then look this is
also our problem you know she committed
a crime she should return to the UK and
be be tried have a fair trial go to
prison if necessary rather than being
left stateless I mean that's not what
the Court held today and as I say I
think there are these concerns about
National Security and there are things
that you know were heard in court that
we that we don't know about because it
was done behind
um closed out the closed doors and I
think that national security issue does
need to be
um the the the priority but look you
know labor has been calling for a long
time for there to be an investigation
into those trafficking elements a
potential trafficking elements and how
you know she came to be radicalized in
the first place
um not just for her case but to make
sure things like this don't happen again
so we have been calling for that as well
and I want to talk to you a little bit
now with your Shadow ministerial uh hat
on labor has been doing an awful lot
about um crime this week there's been a
lot as well of a focus on violence
against women and girls in light of
people's faith in the metropolitan
police as well you know if you are you
know a woman who has experienced a
sexual crime why should you trust in
that place
and I think actually confidence in the
metropolitan police amongst women is a
an all-time low
um
you know we had the shocking case of
David Carrick uh Wayne cousins as well
and confidence is really really low in
the police and I think the new met
Police Commissioner has got a huge
amount of work to do to restraw trust
and confidence of women in London and
their faith in police but there's also a
lot more I think that the government
could be doing
um in terms of tackling violence against
women and girls because it feels like
it's something that has become almost
epidemic in society you know every day
you read the news and you hear about
um another woman being murdered or you
know another case of uh domestic abuse
or serious sexual violence and it does
feel like not enough is being done to
tackle that a lot of people talk as well
about the conviction rates right and
very low chance of if you report a
sexual crime that they actually been
seeing the the perpetration being
brought to Justice I mean are you
worried that you know rape is always
becoming decriminalized I'm really
worried about that um something like 1.6
of reported rapes result in a charge or
a summons
um so it's incredibly low numbers
there's also been a big issue about how
long it's taking cases to get to court
so the average weight for rape victims
waiting for their case to get to court
has gone up to three years three years
when someone's life is on hold where
they're suffering trauma they've got it
hanging over them and actually the
dropout rate is is really high for rape
cases because of that because people
want to move on with their lives and
women tell me that they they don't feel
supported by the system they often feel
like it's working against them rather
than rather than for them and the final
question that I got for you um I
normally hate these kind of anecdotal
things but I actually got checked into
this guy a couple weeks ago and what he
said to me really stayed with me he was
like look you know we're talking rightly
all the time about women and girls in
the Met police but what we're not
talking about enough is race and he said
that we should be talking much more
about how black men in particular are
treated by the police and his own
communities distrust of the Met police
and I thought actually you know he's got
really good point she thought it's
something that you know around the black
lives matters protest we talked about an
awful lot and now it's almost dropped
off the agenda and it's something that
we do still need to be really
considerate about I think it's a really
really important issue and actually
young black men are
um disproportionately represented in the
in the criminal justice system
um and very often that's because they're
more likely to be stops and surged than
uh than the white young men for for
example
um and more needs to be done you know I
was a teenager in the
um in the 1990s when Stephen Lawrence
was murdered for for example
um so I know that distrust sounds I know
for my own constituency some of the
distrust that there is in the police
there is some work that's been going on
to try and sell some Innovations but I
feel the pace of change is not fast
enough what do you think could happen
then well I mean one of the things that
that labor wants to do is introduce the
race equalities act to look at all of
these issues
um uh and some of the structural issues
in society which means that race is
still
um a a a big a big issue okay and thank
you very much great to have you on the
program first time we've had you here